Ciao ragazzi e ciao ragazze
a grande richiesta ecco a voi il video sulle tipologie di fidanzate
Qua con me c'è Edoardo che reciterà con me nel video
tipo
eheheh
la tua fidanzata qual è le tipologie che abbiamo fatto?
mah un po' uno, un po' quattro e cinque anche
okay. E tu?
Ma sai che forse anch'io sono un po' uno, un po' uno
e forse anche un po' otto. Ma aspetta
forse è meglio che se lo guardino. Forse è meglio di si dai. 1 2..
3 Via!
Buon mesiversario amore, due rose per due mesi
grazie amore che carino che ti sei ricordato
No vabbeh questo momento è top. Allora vai indietro, devo assolutamente fare un Instagram stories le mie amiche impazziranno d'invidia. Allora vieni avanti, mi guardi
un po' da, non so dolce e sensuale,
ammicante e mi dici' amore, sei l'unica'. Vai
Amoree, sei unica
Il mio amore mi ha portato due rose per i due mesi
quanto lo amo
entra, aspettami che mi devo preparare
Amore cos'è che hai? è tutto il giorno che sei giù
Ah sì, cos'ho? cos'ho? è tutta la notte
e tutta la notte che ci penso
mi fai schifo
ieri sera, ieri sera  ti ho visto che quella ragazza ti ha salutato
e tu non l'hai salutata soltanto perché c'ero io
ma qualche gatta ci cova, chi cazzo era quella
ti assicuro che non salutava me sennò  l'avrei salutata
ah ma sei lei ti saluta tu la saluti così va bene salutare le tipe così a caso
le stai guardando il culo
stiamo litigando per una tipo e tu le stai guardando il culo mi fai schifo mi fai schifo
no ma non è vero stavo guardando la moto
pronti, usciamo?
amore ma come ti sei vestito? no vabbè ti prego questa camicia neanche per safari park la metterei
cambiati completamente
allora mettiti il completo di Hugo Boss quello burgundy poi la camicia lavanda
e tocco di classe le stringate testa di moro che ti ho regalato per il tuo compleanno
amore...hai sgorregiato?!(urlando)
fai annusare, ti prego
edo: ma no che sti dicendo
maryna: amore dai dobbiamo condividere tutto
ma smettila, non è vero
oh dio che puzza
amore mi dai un bacio?
hai mangiato un chilo di aglio
se mi ami mi baci lo stesso
e dai amore
ma no per favore
amore...
è cambiato qualcosa tra di noi vero?
Lo sento, lo sento lo percepisco
oh mio dio senti senti tutta la vibrazione negativa che mi arrivando da te
senti senti
perché ieri sera mi ha risposto un minuto e trentasette dopo?
di solito non lo fai, è la prima volta, c'hai un'altra
c'è un'altra lo so me lo sento me lo sento. Com'è bella? è bionda ? è più bella di me?
allora fasciettina lo sai che questo ormai lo sai
questa volta no
no no no no no
amore ti giuro che ti fa soltanto bene te lo giuro
allora idratiamo un po' la pelle, non ti faccio male amore guarda ti faccio anche i messaggini
maryna: guarda che bel punto nero
edo:no, quelli no
no! te lo devo sciacciare
ne vale della tua bellezza
edo: non puoi guardare la televisione
maryna : ne vale della tua b...guarda è proprio li che sta per uscire, stai fermo!
bello qua bellissima vista
stupendo
senti anche se è poco che stiamo insieme
volevo dirti ti amo
aaaaa
andiamo al cinema? dai andiamo al cinema, vieni
amore io vado per la partita di calcetto
no amore vengo anch'io.Guarda un due e tre il mio amore è olè anche il balletto
dai amore voglio venire anch'io dai amore non voglio stare tutto il giorno senza di te mi puoi dai per favore  mandare il messaggino quando arrivi,  negli spogliatoi mi mandi una foto nella doccia poi mi mandi il video mentre dormi
non prende il telefono
dai amore dai vengo anch'io andiamo vengo anch'io dai
aspetta amore anch'io anch'io
amore
buon compleanno un regalino per te
grazie amo...
sfiga una chanel nera
Lo sapevi che la volevo cipria
amore hai detto voglio la chanel, voglio la chanel te l'ho presa nera
vedi perché non mi conosci, stiamo insieme da sei mesi dovresti saperlo che mi piace solo il cipria
nera non sporca
certo perché sei un tamarro
tamaro lo dici a quei giargiani dei tuoi amici
sfiga mi hai rovinato il compleanno, io ti lascio
amore lo sai che stai proprio bene truccata così?
davvero? ti piace? da quando mi hai detto che ti piacciono le ragazze truccate mi guardo tutti i tutorial e ora sembro Moira Orfei vero? però solo per te lo faccio
e poi tutti i tatuaggi per sembrare la Chielilli (*) che è la tua preferita vero?
adesso che devo fare, dimmi cosa devo fare
mah se proprio me lo chiedi una bella terza?
dici? ma sai che ci avevo pensato pure io?!
ma se mi faccio una bella quarta che dici ti piacciono di più?
ma si abbondiamo dai
va bene allora chiamo subito il chirurgo, mamma mia quanto ti amo mi faccio le tette solo per te
mi fai le coccole?
mollami non mi stare così addosso però cavolo dai
me l'hai chiesto tu...
ti sei fatto la ceretta? ancora con questi peli, lo sai che mi fanno schifo i peli
edo: avevi detto che ti piacciono..
maryna: no, su gli altri ragazzi su di te no fatti la ceretta
scusa amore mi dispiace... ti sei arrabbiato? dai non volevo ti amo
maryna: oh però calcolami
edo: ma stiamo guardando la televisione
dai oh hai rotto i coglioni basta
tieni ciao
amore no no amore vieni qua amore amore vieni qua scusami scusami
guardiamo la televisione insieme
però basta
basta cosa??(urlando)
amore
dimmi
hai visto per caso la mia felpa verde, il mio pantalone nero e anche la giacchetta di pelle
maryna: ti mancano anche gli occhiali da sole vero?
edo: si li hai spostati tu?
te li ho buttati
dai amore l'altra sera amore che sei uscito con gli amici mi sono presa male pensavo che mi tradissi
e niente ho buttato tutto, due cose da niente dai
edo: tu stai male, ma tu sei da rinchiudere
maryna: esagerato...
ma allora...
sei tu che mi hai cambiato la password di facebook, sono due giorni che non più riesco ad entrare
ci credo, tutte quelle tipe che ti mettevano like insomma mi dava fastidio
lo sai come sono fatta
almeno adesso che non c'è più nessun profilo ne su facebook ne su instagram ne da nessuna parte
nessuno può mettere like, scusa così sono più tranquilla no?
io ho paura
molto bene noi siamo curiosissimi di sapere quale tipologia di fidanzate siete voi
quindi mi raccomando commentate qui sotto
se vi è piaciuto il video iscrivetevi al canale
e seguitemi su i vari social
io vi saluto
e io vado a recuperare i vestiti nel cassonetto
top adoro
ciao
(musica)